right now i am standing on neutral
territory behind the camera is ukraine
over to this side is russia and belarus
is that way the monument behind me is
the three sisters monument a sign of the
friendship of the unification of this
area of course that's not the situation
right now
we have special forces people like who
controls the territory and if something
happen they will be arrived here as soon
as possible
while state border officer alexandra
stupak says they haven't seen an
increase in activity here military
intelligence provides a different view
as many as 30 000 russian forces could
be taking part in military drills on the
belarusian side of the border this is
the biggest russian deployment there
since the cold war
still the three-way border remains open
truckers who have driven the route say
they've seen nothing no zero
zero the hope is that it stays that way
the northern front is peaceful unlike
the donbass region in the east
fighting there has been ongoing since
2014 when russian-backed separatists
captured large areas in the region after
russia annexed crimea the east appears
to be where most ukrainian soldiers are
being deployed but units are on the move
on our drive north from kiev we passed
one convoy
in nearby herodia a russian invasion is
inconceivable
i don't believe how this could happen
because i have my sister there who is
living there and i have my nephews who
is also living there i kinda
understand how this could happen because
we are relatives still some people here
tell global news they'd pick up arms to
defend ukraine
i don't know if you will leave and we
will see only god knows
how it will be
for now the shops are open and trucks
are crossing the border those who patrol
here know peace in this vast
multinational intersection could be
disrupted in an instant crystal
comancing global news senkivca ukraine